[Musique]
1 130 et la mode a pris son rôle sous
les yeux du bailli de suffren qui en a
vu bien d'autres
une mode résolument garçonnière la plus
haute fantaisie et de rigueur sur la
plage et le seul reproche que l'on
puisse faire à cet emballage c'est qu'il
ya tromperie sur la marchandise
cette année le tissu éponge et roy fini
l'antique serviette
iny le peignoir solennel vive la
chasuble et honneur au bikini qui amorce
après une disgrâce injustifiée un
vigoureux retour en chantier le tapis de
sable est devenu utilitaires
[Musique]
quant aux coiffures leur gamme est
infini et leur inspiration des plus
éclectiques
ce puits le bonnet épuisette jusqu'à la
perruque de bain en passant par le
chapeau dessert mais au fond qu'importe
la panoplie l'essentiel n'est-il pas que
le soleil brille et que l'eau soit
limpide
alors vive les vacances
le
[Musique]